aujourd'hui je
on voulait savoir si vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes déjà sorti de votre
gps
carte est ce que vous êtes déjà retrouvé
un peu peut-être là vous êtes n'est
perdu pour venir ici
en tout cas moi j'adore me perdre j'ai
découvert ça il ya quelques années et je
me suis rendu compte que en fait j'adore
être dans des situations comme ça
typiquement aller skier dans le
brouillard
on voit on distingue pas c'est ce qui
nous distingue pas le sol du ciel tout
est blanc on sait plus trop où on va
en fait on se retrouve dans une
situation un petit peu inconfortable
mais un petit peu excitante quand même
d'autres situations que j'aime bien
c'est déambuler dans des villes il ya un
an je partirais hong kong pour le boulot
et je me suis retrouvé à déambuler sans
carte sans guide parce que j'avais pas
acheter un guide pour aller bosser quand
même et je me suis retrouvé dans une
grande ville comme ça avec une journée
complète à tuer et je me suis paumé quoi
j'ai marché j'ai marché j'ai découvert
finalement plein de lieux incroyables
j'ai découvert des gens incroyables et
j'ai évidemment j'avais pas de guide les
pas de carte je suis sorti de cette
carte là et j'ai voilà je suis trouvé ça
incroyable
en fait dans ma vie je me suis beaucoup
perdu de façon professionnelle et aussi
dans la nature
on me présente comme un aventurier c'est
peut-être passage micro
aventuriers mais il ya quelques années
en fait j'ai une expérience qui m'a fait
réaliser que se perdre ça pouvait nous
apporter beaucoup
aujourd'hui je vais essayer de vous
expliquer comment se ré apprendre à se
perdre et comment ça ça peut nous
apporter à sa vie perso beaucoup de
choses mais aussi ça va nous permettre
de réinventer le monde dont il ya
quelques années je suis parti en
montagne avec ma fille qui avait six
mois je les minots mon dos dans un petit
sac de portage et je suis parti avec ma
mère aussi puis on est parti se balader
dans les forêts de chartreuse la
chartreuse c'est un endroit assez
incroyable c'est des forêts hyper
profonde des forêts un peu mystérieuse
c'est moi ça massif que j'adore donc on
est parti avec ma mère on a marché une
petite heure et puis au bout d'un moment
on a pris un embranchement qui était pas
le bon on s'en est rendu compte dix
minutes après en disant ben ouais c'est
vrai que là c'est le il ya moins de
monde
la végétation est plus dense ça doit pas
être là mais moins confiant il perd
confiance en moi je fais tout je pense
que ça va passer quand même on va
retrouver notre petit chemin donc on a
continué on a marché et au bout d'une
demi heure là on s'est dit que ça
devrait être pas être là heureusement un
autre embranchements est arrivé ok on va
prendre suis là je pense que ça va
arriver on va retrouver la voiture
tranquillou ou d'une heure on s'est
rendu compte que là on n'était plus du
tout sur le bon chemin
la végétation avait un peu grandi on
était plutôt bon endroit si je fais un
petit pas de côté
à cette époque là dans ma vie j'étais
exactement comme l'a présenté tout à
l'heure le speaker j'étais dans le
marketing dans une université enfin je
sortais d'une université qui m'avait
poussé à faire du marketing et de la
communication parce que c'est ce que
j'avais choisi au départ et je bossais
dans une grosse boîte américaine qui
vendait des ordi ça me plaisait pas
forcément je me suis dit que j'allais
prendre un autre on mange moins un autre
chemin donc j'ai quitté ce job là qui
était plutôt confortable et je me suis
retrouvé à monter un magasin et qui
portait vraiment mes valeurs j'avais
envie de mettre ça en avant
donc j'ai trouver un associé j'ai monté
un magasin qui vendait des fringues de
skate et de snowboard avec une vocation
environnementale
l'idée c'est de proposer des produits
d'une sélection de produits qui avaient
un impact
deux ans plus tard j'ai lâché ça et j'ai
pris encore un autre chemin j'ai monté
une société de livraison à vélo à
grenoble et je me suis mis à pédaler
toute la journée je me suis fait un
corps de rêve
ça se voit plus maintenant mais pendant
un moment j'étais vraiment gaulle et et
surtout ben ça m'a appris plein de
choses aussi sur moi mais aussi sur sur
les autres
mais le truc c'est que à un moment donné
après avoir fait les gros building et
des gros open space et après avoir roulé
toute la journée et ben ma fille est
arrivée dans ma vie avoir un enfant ça
change tout et surtout ça m'a demandé un
petit habilité stabilité financière
forcément stabilité dans les horaires
quand on fait du vélo de 8 heures le
matin jusqu'à 19 heures le soir
n est pas forcément adapté à gérer la
vie d'un enfant du coup je me suis que
je te retrouve un petit peu de confort
dont j'ai repris une autre voie et je me
suis retrouvé à être vendeur dans un
magasin de sport à part ça c'est sûr
c'est un peu moins excitant et j'ai été
forcément responsable du rayon vélo et à
partir de ce moment là je me suis pas là
et ça te tant pis c'était peut-être mon
chemin quoi au bout de deux ans je me
suis rendu compte que ce n'était pas du
tout mon chemin évidemment et j'ai
arrêté ça donc si je refais un pas de
côté que je reviens un peu en arrière
dans la forêt glam on était perdus avec
ma mère et ma fille dans le dos au bout
de deux heures on a commencé à
s'inquiéter voilà on s'est dit ah là
quand même je pense qu'on est vraiment
fou mais désolé maman je pensais qu'on
allait y arriver mais en fait on n'y est
pas arrivé et on sait plus trop où on
est deux heures de marche faire demi
tour c'est encore plus démotivant je
pense donc moi je voulais absolument pas
faire demi tour
donc on a poussé on a continué et là on
a rencontré vraiment des difficultés
en fait le chemin et qui était un chemin
forestier est devenu un sentier est
devenue une petite santé serpentant dans
la forêt finalement c'est devenu
quasiment rien donc y avait quasiment
plus de chemin des fougères autres comme
ça et surtout comme dans tous les bons
films
évidemment il s'est mis à pleuvoir donc
moi j'avais ma fille dans l'eau donc je
dis un petit bébé de six mois dans le
dos elle n'était pas hyper confort moi
j'étais surtout un petit peu mal pour
elle et ma mère commence à s'inquiéter
donc on était dans une situation un peu
un peu compliqué et surtout à la lan
panique en entraînant une autre à
l'ambiance est pas forcément au beau
fixe on part on peut donc commencer à
s'engueuler etc c'était pas l'expédition
de l'année 1 ok mais par contre quand
les ai quand même perdu depuis deux
heures et tout ça pour vous dire que à
ce moment là on en a un petit peu bavé
et ont commencé à s'engueuler ce n'était
pas cool
donc on s'est dit qu'il fallait qu'on
sert un petit peu l'écoutent quoi on
s'est regardés on avait la
responsabilité de ma fille de 6 mois
dans le dos donc il va falloir qu'on
fasse quelque chose
on était sortis complètement de cette
carte là on est plus de gps pas de
connexion c'est pas tous les jours que
ça arrive mais ça fait du bien le truc
si je refais un pas de côté que je
reviens dans ma vie à ce moment là j'ai
aussi pratiqué ce type de sport là ça
s'appelle du bike polo
s'il y en a un super club annecy et
c'est un sport complètement émergents
c'est un sport qui est assez rigolo et
c'est aussi surtout une communauté très
très forte à cette époque là j'ai fait
les championnats de france de bike polo
parce que quand on est un sport
émergents on peut faire les championnats
du monde c'est super facile mais là
c'était les joints de france gt avoriaz
en pleine montagne dans un sur un
terrain de tennis à faire le championnat
de france
et là j'ai discuté avec une fille qui
m'a dit ah écoute moi je suis
intervenante dans une formation à l'iut
d'annecy
juste à côté un essai une formation qui
parle d'outdoor qui parle
d'environnement et qui parle de textiles
techniques aussi et moi je les regarde
et je fais mes amis c'est exactement ce
que cherche quoi c'est ça ça c'est mon
chemin quoi ça c'est un truc que je rêve
de faire depuis tout gamin
du coup j'ai laissé tomber mon vélo je
suis descendu de la montagne et je me
suis inscrit deux jours après je suis
allé voir à lutter et mâcher de déposer
mon dossier d'inscription à ce moment là
j'étais un petit peu paumé dans ma vie
forcément j'étais entre entre ce job de
vendeur en magasin donc c'est pour moi
c'était quand même nous un gros espoir
quoi j'y suis allé la rentrée suivante
j'étais inscrit j'ai été accepté et je
suis rentré en formation continue
formation continue et ça veut dire
investir pas mal d'argent repayer
reprendre des études déjà à 30 ans
j'avais un peu plus de 30 ans il faut
repayer il faut donner des souffles
parce que l'université coûte très cher
attention et à ce moment là moi j'avais
pas d'argent du tout quoi j'étais
vendeur chez go sport je pouvais pas me
payer cette formation là donc j'ai dû
aller demander à ma famille demandé à
mes amis qui m'ont aidé et qui m'ont
voilà qui m'ont soutenu dans ce projet
là ça a été un moment facile j'étais le
plus âgé donc complètement en décalage
avec les gens qui était dans ma classe
qui avaient entre 20 et 22 ans et la
dernière chose c'est que surtout j'étais
ainsi alors moi j'habite à grenoble donc
tous les jours je prenais ma voiture je
prenais un covoiture prenait le train
pour venir à la fac le matin à 8h30 et
qui repartir le soir 17 ou 18 heures
inutile de dire je voyais plus ma fille
je voyais plus mes enfants enfin je
n'avais plus ma femme est plus ma fille
et s'était pas forcément évident ça a
créé des tensions
et là j'ai quitté ma femme
c'est pas vrai en fait elle a été là
jusqu'au bout elle m'a soutenu et
heureusement parce que sinon je serais
pas là aujourd'hui
elle m'a vraiment vraiment poussé
positivement dans ce projet là et c'est
un peu grâce à elle que je suis là donc
j'étais sur les bancs de cette fac là et
là j'ai découvert un nouveau monde
j'ai découvert une nouvelle communauté
cette formation était très proche de la
goutte-d'or que des intervenants
extérieurs donc j'y vois la découverte
ce nouveau réseau si je reviens à ce
moment là où j'étais avec ma mère dans
la forêt il ya un moment donné on a
senti quelque chose se passait on a vu
toutes ces difficultés on a commencé à
s'engueuler on met par contre on savait
qu'il fallait qu'on s'en sorte on s'est
serré les coudes
notre sens d'orientation on a essayé de
le pousser au maximum de regarder
d'observer etc et au détour d'une
vieille cabane on a senti qu'il y avait
une odeur différente dans la forêt
quelque chose voilà c'était pas la même
chose on n'était plus dans l'humidité ou
depuis on était depuis trois heures et
en fait on a débarqué dans cette
clairière où d'un coup là tout s'est
ouvert la forêt s'est ouverte et là
c'est ça a été un moment magique ça doit
être une micro aventure ça nous a
vraiment pris aux tripes
en fait à partir du moment où on sort de
ces claria tour revient pas nos repères
les montagnes aux alentours la forez
s'arrête là il continua pleuvait il
continue à pleuvoir ne s'était pas
forcément parfait non plus mais par
contre on avait un
on avait un peu se passe de moments de
libération moment intense on a presque
envie de pleurer quoi et ça on était
arrivé parce qu'on s'était serré les
coudes on l'avait fait ensemble mois
quelques années plus tard quand j'étais
assortis de 7 cette formation adulte et
j'avais découvert un nouvel
environnement
mais j'avais surtout rencontré quelqu'un
qui m'a ouvert les portes de son projet
d'entreprise
cette personne là c'est mon actuel
associé benjamin qui m'a montré que on
pouvait créer une entreprise à partir
d'une seule idée une seule vision lui ce
qu'ils voulaient c'était changer le
monde va ce projet
j'y vais moi ça m'a plu et je lui dis
bâclé je dis moi je veux bien
t'accompagner là dedans je veux bien
qu'on ait des dons qu'il m'a embauchée
je suis entré en tant que salarié un an
après je suis devenu associé dans cette
entreprise qui s'appelle aircop notre
but dans ceux de boîte
ces deux d'avoir un impact positif sur
nos écosystèmes
on était trois au départ on était dos au
départ qu'on est devenu 3 on vivait une
expérience plutôt positive
on avait un vrai impact sur nos
écosystèmes qui était plutôt restreint
l'outdoor les territoires de montagne
sauf que on pensait que c'était pas
assez quoi on voulait plus voulait plus
d'argent on voulait avoir plus d'impact
notre volonté c'était ne pas se limiter
à trois personnes et ne pas se limiter à
juste quelques quelques missions et nos
quelques missions donc on a transformé
l'entreprise et on est allé chercher
d'un bonnet qui pouvait nous
correspondent un peu plus on a
transformé l'entreprise en une
coopérative qui n'était pas au départ
et surtout on a hacké un petit peu le
modèle des coopératives pour pouvoir
nous adapter à ce qu'on voulait vraiment
faire à vouloir vraiment avoir un impact
significatif sur le monde aujourd'hui on
est un peu plus d'une dizaine à tout le
monde n'est pas sur la photo
et tous ces gens là malgré leurs métiers
différents ont tous un impact positif
sur le monde
je me suis beaucoup perdu dans la vie
mais là je crois que j'ai vraiment
trouvé ma petite clairière
je suis vraiment sortis de la forêt et
j'ai trouvé le bon chemin qui moi me
rend heureux et en plus un impact sur le
monde donne du sens à ma vie quoi
vraiment
je voulais finir soit un truc moi
aujourd'hui j'ai réappris à me perdre
dans la nature parce que je kiffe ça je
trouve ça rigolo de se perdre je suis
sorti un peu de cette carte mais aussi
dans la vie et quand on se perd
finalement on explore plein de chemins
différents et on se rend compte que
c'est souvent là qu'on trouve du sens
dans sa vie aujourd'hui je pense qu' il
faut arrêter de ceux de partir sur des
plans tout fait dans votre vie et il
faut aller explorer d'autres choses
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
qu'est ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
moi je pense qu'ils g3 conseil à vous
donner le premier c'est de prendre un
petit post it ou prendre un petit
feuille de papier et marquer tout de
suite quel serait le rêve dans votre vie
quoi qu'est ce que vous voudriez faire
pour donner du sens pour vous sentir
utile dans la société dans le monde
qu'est ce que vous devez faire de votre
vie un projet pro un projet perso ou
autre notez le sur un petit papier collé
le sur votre frigo et puis essayer
d'explorer différents chemins essayer de
prendre plein d'embranchements différent
et pas rester forcément là où vous êtes
maintenant vous êtes peut-être dans une
formation de marketing ou de vente ou
autre allez voir autre chose peut-être
quelque chose qui vous mènera à ce
niveau là le deuxième conseil s'est
faite le ensemble dans la forêt si
j'avais été tout seul ça aurait pas été
la même que si j'étais avec ma mère et
ma fille on réagit pas de la même façon
si j'avais pas rencontrer tous ces gens
dans ses projets professionnels
j'en serais pas là aussi aujourd'hui si
ma femme n'avait pas été là je ne serais
pas là aujourd'hui
donc fait le ensemble aujourd'hui c'est
pas possible de faire des choses tout ça
ne peut pas sauver le monde tout seul et
le dernier conseil
surtout c'est ne vous arrêtez pas
vraiment aux côtés aux côtés je veux
faire je veux gagner de l'argent quoi
aujourd'hui c'est pas ça aujourd'hui on
est face à une urgence climatique
une urgence environnementale sociale
aussi sur lequel on peut plus attendre
il faut le faire maintenant
moi j'ai fait ça j'avais 30 ans quand
j'ai changé de vie et aujourd'hui on
peut plus pas les gens sont dans la rue
vous êtes dans la rue on peut plus
attendre pour avoir un impact positif
sur le monde
vous allez vous aider vous même en
donnant du sens à votre vie mais vous
allez aussi l'aider le monde donc bougez
vous allez-y
et je finir avec juste une petite phrase
tirée d'une chanson qui dit que c'est
pas nous qui marche ont pas droit
c'est le monde qui va de travers ce
n'est pas nous qui marche ont pas droit
on a beau prendre plein d'embranchements
plein de chemin différent c'est pas
grave on vous prendra
vous avez peut-être penser qu'on va vous
prendre pour quelqu'un d'un peu bizarre
mais non en fait c'est le monde qui va
de travers et il faut qu on le répare
donc osé sortir
oser explorer d'autres chemins aurait
provoqué le monde alesi et surtout
réinventer le monde
merci
[Applaudissements]